[Musik]
der teil nationalpark tief im regenwald
der elfenbeinküste einen schimpansen
kind hat seine mutter verloren leoparden
haben die äffin gerissen
nun ist der kleine auf sich gestellt
noch hat er zu essen
doch allein wird er nicht überlegen ob
sich jemand aus der affengruppe in der
er mit seiner mutter bisher gelebt hat
um ihn kümmern wird
sind ihre fähig sich in andere
hineinzuversetzen haben es ihr mitgefühl
sorgen sie sich um den anderen sind sie
empathisch altruistisch und gar gericht
[Musik]
neue erkenntnisse aus der
verhaltensforschung scheinen zu
revolutionieren was man bisher über die
gefühlswelt der tiere wusste
[Musik]
ohne hilfe ist das waisenkind verloren
es versucht zwar im alleingang an
nahrung zu kommen aber es klappt nicht
schimpansen lernen durch nachahmung von
ihren müttern nur ein erwachsenes
erfahrenes tier kann ihm beibringen mit
welchen stücken oder steinen man die
harten nüsse geknackt
die schimpansen sind mit nahrungssuche
und mit der aufzucht des eigenen
nachwuchses beschäftigt das genetisch
nicht verwandte tiere sich um die
jungtiere von anderen kümmern kommt im
tierreich sehr selten vor
[Musik]
im max planck institut für evolutionäre
anthropologie werten die
verhaltensforscher die beobachtungen aus
diesem teil nationalpark sammeln leiter
des teams ist roman wichtig da gibt es
ein breites spektrum an verschiedenen
verhaltensweisen
das kann sehr aggressiv sein gegenüber
dem waisenkind das kann sehr neutral
sein und es kommt ein bisschen drauf an
wie das verhältnis von den tieren zur
mutter des weißen kind zwar zum beispiel
die anderen gruppenmitglieder sehen
natürlich das waisenkind sehr sehr
häufig auch als konkurrenten an
und damit ist es verständlich dass nicht
jeder dem kind helfen möchte schlechte
aussichten für victor so nennen die
wissenschaftler das waisenkind
das york hieß primatenzentrum der emory
university ist eine der ältesten tier
beobachtungsstationen der welt
verhaltensforscher franzke war leitet
das living links center und hält
vorlesungen auf der ganzen welt in der
wissenschaft herrscht weitgehend
einigkeit darüber dass tiere über
einzelne grund emotionen wie angst und
freude verfügen
doch franz der wahl war der erste der
die these aufstellte dass im tierischen
miteinander auch komplexere emotionen
wie empathie eine wesentliche rolle
spielen beim teilen von nur einer
wassermelone für zwölf schimpansen geht
es ausgesprochen ruhig und entspannt zu
[Musik]
was wir hier sehen nennen wir jeweiliger
besitz das heißt wer das futter zuerst
hat es muss nicht mal der ranghöchste
sein kann es auch behalten und die
anderen die sind sehr höflich sie reißen
ist im anderen nicht aus der hand oder
schlagen hin
sie warten einfach dass sie auch etwas
abbekommen versuchen höchstens muss man
anzufassen
im besitz der wassermelone
[Musik]
sie versucht sich abzusetzen und die
ganze frucht für sich zu behalten
wenn sich ein individuum so verhält wird
es in zukunft schwierigkeiten haben von
den anderen futter zu bekommen
auf lange sicht lohnt sich egoismus
nicht eine der wichtigsten strategien im
tierreich lautet anscheinend kooperation
[Musik]
schon anfang des vergangenen
jahrhunderts wurde an der emory
university in atlanta ein experiment mit
schimpansen gemacht eine kiste die so
schwer ist dass ein schimpanse allein
sich ziehen kann ist mit leckeren
bananen stücken belegt gemeinsam ziehen
die schimpansen sie heran
[Musik]
wenn einer aufhört weil er keine lust
mehr hat macht ihm der andere schnell
klar dass er weiter ziehen soll
[Musik]
man kooperiert wenn man da von einem
gewinn hat den ball allein nicht hätte
die allereinfachsten form der
kooperation ist das zusammenleben in
einer herde ist man geschützt und nicht
so verletzt aber es gibt viele tierarten
die gehen einen schritt weiter
sie helfen sich sie teilen ihr futter
sie tun viele dinge gemeinsam die sie
allein nicht retten
überall im tierreich ist zusammenarbeit
weit verbreitet 19.11 leben hier im
rudel fast wie in der natur
allerdings sind sie von menschen
aufgezogen und an menschen gewöhnt wölfe
sollen ausgesprochen fair und gerecht
miteinander umgehen die
verhaltensbiologen friederike range und
kurt kotrschal wollen das verhalten der
tiere mit wissenschaftlichen methoden
und modernster technik erforschen
hier steht das größte laufband der welt
es wurde extra für das wolf science
center angefertigt
zunächst werden die wölfe eingewöhnt
später sollen sie gemeinsam laufen hebt
gemeinsames laufen die soziale
verbundenheit auf solche fragen wollen
die wissenschaftler dann im experiment
unter laborbedingungen antworten finden
aber heute geht es darum die
teamfähigkeit der wölfe zu untersuchen
sind sie ebenso wie schimpansen in der
lage komplizierte aufgaben gemeinsam zu
lösen
deshalb führen die wissenschaftler auch
mit ihnen den string pulling test den
schnur zieht es durch
dabei kommen die tiere nur an futter
wenn sie zusammenarbeiten lösen sich
aufeinander einstellen müssen
das heißt wenn einer nur zieht an dem
band dann zieht das band da ganz raus
und dann können sie die plattform nicht
mehr bewegen dies werde versucht
natürlich weiter hinten und dann zieht
das band einfach raus wenn aber beide
ziehen dann ziehen sie das einfach zur
öffentlich trennung kommen dann an das
futter ran
das heißt sie müssen nicht wirklich
koordinieren und synchronisieren
jetzt muss der apparat nur noch mit
fleischstücken präpariert werden dann
können die wölfe kommen um es ihnen
nicht zu leicht zu machen lassen die
wissenschaftler die tiere nicht
gleichzeitig ins versuchsgelände sondern
eher zeitlichem abstand wird aragon der
jüngere wolf schon an dem seil ziehen
bevor caspar der ältere und leiter des
rudels hinzukommt aragon kann sich
beherrschen
erfolgreich meistern die wölfe die
aufgabe
[Musik]
forschungsstation heidelauf haben sind
schlaue vögel
sie sind sogar in der lage zu betrügen
ist genug futter da wird es in einem
versteck deponiert dabei sind sich haben
offensichtlich bewusst ob sie beobachtet
werden
zb tun sie nur so als ob sie futter
verstecken wenn der andere zuschaut
chrome schotterweg verstecken sie es
jedoch an einem anderen ort
[Musik]
können haben auch kooperieren werden
diese individualisten gemeinsam den
string pulling test bestehen
für hunde leckerli tun sie alles sagt
thomas buchner und bestimmt das amt
[Musik]
rabenvögel die gemeinsam an einem strang
ziehen
tatsächlich es klappt das ist das
interessant weil wenn sie diese
kooperation aufgaben am anfang bekommen
dann scheint es für sie darum zu gehen
so schnell vielleicht sehr schnell als
der andere
und noch eine gewisse zeit kommen sie
darauf ein hoppala
das ist eigentlich falsch und dann
fangen sie haben eben auch zu warten bis
dann da ist sie schauen ob deutschland
ist nur genommen hat und all diese dinge
[Musik]
joshua plotnik erforscht die soziale
intelligenz von elefanten
der verhaltensbiologe hat an der new
york university gelehrt dann ist er für
seine forschungen ins goldene dreieck
nach thailand gegangen um dort mit
elefanten zu arbeiten
[Musik]
im riesigen eigens für elefanten
gebauten freiluft labor sind alle
spiegel aus besonderen material sonst
legen sie bald in scherben
denn der elefantenbulle will ganz genau
wissen wie er aus die elefanten bewegen
sich vor dem spiegel vor und zurück als
würden sie sich fragen warum macht
dieses tier immer genau das was ich
gerade mache und dann kommen sie
dahinter und wechseln zu einem verhalten
das wir selbst bezogen bei diesem
klassischen test wird im elefanten eine
markierung an einer stelle des körpers
angebracht die er nur mit hilfe eines
spiegels sehen kann wird er diese
markierung weiß ich selber entfernen
wollen oder bei demgegenüber im spiegel
bisher haben diesen test nur
menschenaffen delfine und elstern
bestanden
dank joshua plotnik weiß man auch
elefanten erkennen sich selbst im
spiegel
[Musik]
varianten des trink tests werden auch
bei elefanten durchgeführt kann der
elefant warten wenn der zweite erst viel
später dazu kommt wir haben den
elefanten einen sehr langen tisch
gegeben weil wir keine schwere kiste
hatten die hätte tausende von pfund
schwer sein müssen damit ein elefant sie
nicht mehr allein hätte ziehen können
wir haben ihnen also diesen langen tisch
gegeben und ein seil drum herum gezogen
die elefanten lernten sehr schnell dass
sie ein ende des seils nehmen und dann
aber warten mussten wir verzögerten
sogar die ankunft ihres partners und sie
warteten bevor sie am seil zogen
[Musik]
wenn ein elefant zugang zum seil hatte
der andere aber nicht weil wir das
andere sei lände aufgerollt hatten oder
sonst irgendwie verhinderten dass er das
seil erreichen konnte
dann versuchte es der erste gar nicht
mehr er gab auf und ging weg und das
zeigte dass er verstanden oder gelernt
hatte
dass es sinnlos ist zu ziehen wenn der
andere elefant nicht mitmacht und noch
etwas haben manche elefanten gelernt
dass der eine die ganze arbeit machen
muss während der andere lediglich den
fuß auf das seil stellt kooperation
setzt voraus die fähigkeiten und die
bedürfnisse des anderen zu verstehen
sich zu synchronisieren und im wahrsten
sinne des wortes an einem strang zu
ziehen
eine strategie die zum erfolg führt
tiere sind bereit konflikte zu lösen und
fürsorglich miteinander umzugehen das
scheint mindestens ebenso wichtig wie
sich gegenseitig zu bekämpfen
ich entdeckte dass schimpansen sich nach
einem kampf gegenseitig umarmten und
küssten und das fand ich viel
interessanter als die aggression
konflikte sind normal am besten ist er
sieger denn es ist schlechter verlierer
zu sein
damals war das tatsächlich schon alles
was man über das thema wusste
mich interessierte aber wie sie
konflikte lösen warum sie konflikte
lösen und ich beobachtete dass sich die
tiere um ihre beziehungen bemühten und
versuchten ihre konflikte zu überwinden
und wie sieht es mit der fähigkeit von
tieren aus sich in menschen
hineinzuversetzen
im clever dog lab an der uni wien
schauen sich hunde die gesichter
fröhlicher und ärgerlicher menschen an
doch versteht der husky rüde partie was
hinter der mimik steckt
[Musik]
die wissenschaftler setzten einen
sogenannten eye tracker ein ein gerät
das die augenbewegungen registriert
[Musik]
so kann man verfolgen welche bereiche
des gesichtes petit anschaut und wir
können das sehr wohl unterscheiden was
für emotionen das menschliche gesicht
zeigt man hat zum beispiel auf den
ergebnissen die die wir gerade eben auch
schon gesehen haben gesehen dass ein
hund ein ärgerliches gesicht
er vermeidet anzugucken das ist
natürlich nicht bei jedem hund so aber
bei dem spezifischen hund hier ist es so
gewesen er vermeidet halt eher in das
ärgerliche gesicht zu schauen ein
fröhliches gesicht wird dabei aber sehr
wohl angesehen wenn hunde zwischen
verschiedenen gesichtsausdrücken
unterscheiden können erkennen sie denn
auch die emotionen die dahinter stehen
[Musik]
der österreichische verhaltensbiologe
ludwig huber und sein team machen einen
versuch
[Musik]
mischlingsrüde toni soll am touchscreen
zwischen fröhlichen und ärgerlichen
gesichtern unterscheiden
keine leichte aufgabe für den hund denn
die wissenschaftler zeigen ihm nur teile
von menschlichen gesicht wie der hund im
kopfe vollständigen muss
das ist für die wissenschaftler ein
indiz dass toni die gesichtsausdrücke
nicht nur auswendig gelernt hat sondern
versteht
wir wollen herausfinden wie uns menschen
versteht und was er an uns versteht und
wenn hunde sozusagen die menschliche
emotion erkennen würde
also wir sind traurig wir sind glücklich
wir sind zornig dann könnte das
sozusagen auf den hund übertragen werden
das darum anspricht auf diese emotion
diese emotion teilt und über diesen
mechanismus auch die emotionen des
menschen versteht
gilt das auch für die begehrten
nutztiere die schweine bereits vor
einigen jahren hat die kognition
forschung erkannt wie intelligent
schweine sind aber sind sie auch
empathisch die tierärztin marie anne
konradt will fühlt dass messerli
institut in wien herausfinden ob
schweine sich in menschen
hineinversetzen können eines kann sich
jetzt schon sagen schweine sind
ausgesprochen gelehrig
vorderseite und rückseite von personen
zu unterscheiden ist für sie eine
leichte aufgabe
[Musik]
meistens
und auch das erkennen von fröhlichen und
zornigen gesichtern scheint für schweine
kein problem zu sein wenn die lektion
beendet ist ist es schwierig das tier
aus dem lernbereich wieder
herauszubekommen was vielleicht an den
leckeren salzstangen liegt
marianne wondrak versucht es mit lob
wenn gar nichts mehr hilft mit sanfter
gewalt für die tierärztin ist klar dass
schweine emotional bisher unterschätzt
wurden
es ist ja auch noch so dass dieses
projekt hier auch noch einen ethischen
hintergrund hat es geht also auch um die
ethischen implikationen aus dem was wir
finden diese studie ist dreigeteilt der
hauptteil liegt in der
kognitionsforschung dann haben wir einen
teil in der komparativen medizin es
kommt ja auch zum messer die institute
dazu und der dritte teil ist der
ethische teil und die ethischen
implikationen aus dem was man hier
findet und da ist natürlich das große
thema warum lieben wie hunde und warum
essen wir schweine
eine frage die einleuchtet
[Musik]
an der altarwand universität wollen
verhaltensbiologen wissen was dran ist
an der meinung dass hunde ihre besitzer
verstehen
die idee hinter unseren versuchen ist
dass hundebesitzer oft behaupten ihre
hunde seien ihnen gegenüber empathisch
wenn sie zb traurig sein dann würden die
hunde ebenfalls zeichen von traurigkeit
zeigen sie würden versuchen sie zu
trösten und emotionalen beistand leisten
zwei völlig gleichartige flaschen werden
von der besitzerin entweder begeistert
oder voller abscheu bewertet
euro
[Musik]
welche von den beiden flaschen wird der
hund bringen wenn er dazu aufgefordert
wird die flasche die seine besitzerin
schön findet oder die die sie
verabscheut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist damit der wissenschaftliche beweis
erbracht dass hunde sich tatsächlich in
menschen hineinversetzen können dass sie
im badisch sind
[Musik]
wir können natürlich nur das verhalten
der hunde beobachten
wir wissen nicht was in den hunden
tatsächlich vorgeht welche gefühle sie
haben in dieser situation wir haben
festgestellt dass die hunde sich dem
verhalten ihrer besitzer anpassen
das ist ein ganz deutliches anzeichen
von empathie man kann ein tier nicht
fragen was es denkt es ist unser größtes
hindernis auf dem weg ihren geist zu
erforschen
beim menschen ist das etwas anderes man
kann fragen wie fühlst du dich
sie geben dann eine hoffentlich ehrliche
antwort und du kannst auf ihre emotionen
entschließen das geht bei tieren nicht
stattdessen müssen wir experimente
machen oder ihr natürliches verhalten
beobachten und versuchen es zu
interpretieren
auf der basis unserer bisherigen
erfahrungen diesen tieren
victor ist immer noch allein
langsam gehen ihm die vorräte aus die
wissenschaftler die das drama beobachten
greifen nicht ein
die tiere sollen in ihrem natürlichen
verhalten nicht gestört werden
der einzige der den kleinen überhaupt
zur kenntnis zu nehmen scheint ist regel
ein starkes alphamännchen
doch victor hält distanz
wenn sich so ein kleiner knirps einem
erwachsenen menschen an nähert kann das
natürlich auch immer aggressiv enden für
den kleinen clubs und das heißt diese
annäherung mag vielleicht gar nicht
deswegen so vorsichtig passieren weil
viktor sich nicht bewusst oder bei
viktor denkt der freddy steht jetzt auf
und geht weg
ja sondern ich denke er hat vielleicht
eher das gefühl oh gott der steht auf
und haut mir vielleicht eine mär
das heißt so eine beziehung wie bei uns
menschen muss immer was aufgebaut werden
beziehung sind nicht einfach nur da die
brauchen eine phase in der sie aufgebaut
werden und dann müssen sie immer wieder
bestätigt werden zwischen den beiden
viktor hat bisher ohne unterstützung
überlebt könnte der riesige schimpansen
man eine hoffnung für ihn sein
um mehr über hilfsbereite tiere zu
erfahren muss man hierher reisen an der
altehrwürdigen university of chicago
arbeitet die neurobiologin perry mason
mit ihren versuchen zu mitfühlenden
uneigennützigen tieren hat die
wissenschaftlerin viele ihrer kollegen
in erstaunen versetzt ihre protagonisten
ganz normale ratten in einer kleinen
arena kann eine ratte sich frei bewegen
während eine zweite in eine enge
plexiglas röhre gesperrt ist
sie kann sich nicht aus eigener kraft
befreien die käfigtür lässt sich nur von
außen öffnen
sie ist auf hilfe durch die freie rate
angewiesen
[Musik]
das erste was wir sahen war dass die
freie retter ins zentrum des versuchs
bereiches ging das ist ungewöhnlich
wattens halten sich normalerweise im
randbereich auf nischen und ecken mögen
sie am liebsten
das ist das revolutionäre erbe sie
vermeiden offenes gelände
denn da könnten sie gefressen werden
obwohl es sie also nervös macht ins
zentrum zu gehen machen sie es trotzdem
offenbar weil sie von der gefangenen
ratte angezogen werden und da wussten
wir dass sie etwas fühlten
denn wenn es keinen gefangenen
artgenossen im zentrum gab sind sie da
auch nicht hingegangen
[Musik]
was wird die rate tun und tatsächlich
nach einer langen zeit des schnupfens
und der kunden öffnet die freie rate die
tür und befreit ihre artgenossen
am ersten tag verbringen die ratten viel
zeit im zentrum aber sie kriegen nicht
unbedingt raus wo da eine tür ist
geschweige denn wie man sie öffnet
aber weil sie sich so lange im zentrum
aufhalten
öffnen sie schließlich doch die tür
meistens eher aus zufall aber das ist
wissenschaftlich gesehen kein resultat
die frage ist was wird die rate am
nächsten tag tun denn das ist
klassisches zielgerichtetes behalten
du hast etwas getan es fühlt sich gut an
und du wirst es wieder tun
in jedem der weiteren versuche befreit
die ratte die eingesperrte artgenossen
perry mason und ihr team haben
herausgefunden dass radler hilfe und zur
selbstlosen verhalten in der lage sind
da ist trotz dieser ergebnisse noch
viele zweifler gab entschloss perry
mason sich zu einem weiteren experiment
[Musik]
das schokoladen experiment haben wir
gemacht um die leute zu überzeugen
also das ist den ratten wirklich darum
geht zu helfen
wir waren uns total sicher aber die
kritiker unserer arbeit zweifelten noch
immer als ich das hörte wurde mir klar
sie konnten es einfach nicht glauben
deshalb wollte ich das experiment noch
einmal machen und zwar so dass es
diesmal jedem sofort einleuchten sollte
ich sagte also okay lasst uns zwei
behälter nehmen einen mit der gefangenen
ratte und einen mit schoko flocken und
dann lassen wir sie wählen was niemand
vermutete geschah die freie rate
befreite ihre artgenossen um sich dann
gemeinsam mit ihr über die schoko
flocken herzumachen sind ratten also
mitfühlend uneigennützig und hilfsbereit
zeit unsere vorurteile über bord zu
werfen nicht nur den ratten gegenüber es
gibt einen grundlegenden impuls jemandem
zu helfen die in schwierigkeiten ist wir
haben das bei bonobos untersucht wo
einer einen anderen der not ist in den
arm nimmt und tröstet
[Musik]
diese art reaktion auf die nöte von
anderen ist sehr spontan und grundlegend
und kommt bei vielen später auch bei
hunden tiere machen das auch gegenüber
in die bibel mit denen sie gar keine
verbindung haben und von denen sie keine
gegenleistung erwarten
[Musik]
was ist die voraussetzung für die
fähigkeit zur hilfsbereitschaft und
selbstlosigkeit unter welchen
bedingungen gehen tiere so weit dass sie
futter für andere organisieren ohne
selbst welche zu bekommen
die forscherin judith burkhardt vom
anthropologischen institut der
universität zürich möchte dass mit
diesem einfachen apparat heraus senden
ihre testkandidaten heute krallenaffen
auch weißbüscheläffchen genannt
[Musik]
an der plattform ziehen sich den
leckeren wurm greifen das gelingt gut
[Musik]
doch jetzt liegt der wurm im napf auf
der anderen seite
[Musik]
was man hier sieht ist wie ungemein
tolerant die sind also die manipulieren
gemeinsamen apparatus die schauen sich
dabei zu und es gibt keine großen
spannungen in diesem kontext toleranz
ist also die voraussetzung für
kooperation gegenseitige hilfe und
unterstützung
[Musik]
diese toleranz kann nicht jede spezies
aufbringen bei den totenkopfäffchen gibt
es bereits bei der vorbereitung des
versuchs konflikte nachdem der chef
aller anderen weg geschickt hat versucht
er den wurm allein zu angeln
natürlich vergeblich denn alle die ihm
helfen könnten hat er dick gebissen
[Musik]
soziale toleranz ist eine ganz wichtige
voraussetzung dafür dass man überhaupt
als richtig handeln kann weil wenn
keiner da ist dann kann man auch
niemandem was geben
bei den kindern gibt es statt würmern
smarties so wird ihre selbstlosigkeit
auf eine harte probe gestellt
eins macht die arbeit und das andere
bekommt etwas dafür
[Musik]
menschen finden das vielleicht nicht
immer gerecht aber sie können sich
überwinden auch wenn es schwer fällt
[Musik]
was meine ganze ist dass sie das ganze
relativ ähnlich wie die krallenaffen
lösen also die schaffen es schon sich zu
koordinieren
sie ziehen auch füreinander auch wenn
sie das nicht immer nur gern machen aber
sie können doch über ihren eigenen
schatten springen und uns dann halt
dass schimpansen waisenkind viktor und
das alphamännchen freddie sind sich
näher gekommen
nach tagen des gegenseitigen taxieren
scheint das vertrauen aufgebaut
viktor traut sich auf reddy's rücken
wir hatten in dem fall von freddy und
victor schon das gefühl dass in dem
moment wo victor zum ersten mal auf
freddys rücken reiten durfte dass das
ein schlüsselerlebnis war das vielleicht
die beziehung bestätigt hat die die
beiden angefangen haben aufzubauen
freddy hat sich victors angenommen
das affenmännchen sorgt jetzt für das
kleinere schimpansen kind
er lässt sich von victor sogar das essen
weg nehmen doch warum tut etwas hat
freddy tatsächlich mitgefühl mit dem
waisenkind zu einem mann mag in gewissen
fällen nutzen daraus ziehen wenn er ein
männliches waisenkind adoptiert und das
durch bringt ja dass dieser dieses
adoptierte kind irgendwann erwachsen
wird 15 jahre später ja und dann die
gruppe mehr männer hat und damit stärker
ist und damit besser in die konkurrenz
mit den nachbar gruppen treten kann
man könnte sagen da ist ein gewisser
nutzen der aber 15 jahren der zukunft
liegt also ist der rückschluss nur der
am wahrscheinlichsten ist dass
tatsächlich eine art von mitgefühl
dieses verhalten erft emotionen wie
mitgefühl entstehen im gehirn im
max-planck-institut für kognitions- und
neurowissenschaften untersuchen
neurologen das ausmaß des menschlichen
mitgefühls in einer laborsituation einer
probanden im mrt werden videos
vorgeführt
meine frau und ich
mittels einer skala soll die probanden
das ausmaß ihres mitgefühls angeben
die wissenschaftler messen den grad der
jeweiligen gehirnaktivität der
untersuchung die wir jetzt gerade
gesehen haben da untersuchen wir unter
anderem empathie und mitgefühl also die
frage wie sehr schwingen wir emotional
mit jemand anderes mit
und wie viel mitgefühl haben wir auch
für diese person und das machen wir
darüber dass wir kurze videofilme zeigen
in denen leute etwas erzählen aus ihrem
leben und das kann dramatisch sein kann
was trauriges sein eigenes aus deren
leben und die frage ist dann was
passiert wenn wir so etwas trauriges
oder emotionales aus deren leben sehen
dass lebewesen mitfühlen mit lachen mit
weinen können liegt an den sogenannten
spiegelneuronen nervenzellen die die
voraussetzung dafür schaffen dass man
sich in den anderen hineinversetzen kann
die spiegelneuronen senden bereits
signale ans gehirn wenn man eine
gefühlsregung nur beobachtet man
empfindet dann dasselbe wie sein
gegenüber den neurologen ist es gelungen
den teil im gehirn zu lokalisieren der
für die empathie also das
einfühlungsvermögen zuständig ist
in den auswertungen kann der neurologe
erkennen in welchem umfang diese region
aktiv wird
warum aber sollte das nur bei menschen
so sein schließlich ist der mensch
biologisch gesehen ein säugetier
also solche untersuchungen über
verschiedene spezies hinweg zeigen ja
dass bestimmte teile des gehirns sich
ähneln und gerade auch eben teile die
beim menschen auch sehr wichtig für
emotionen sind und da liegt es natürlich
nahe zu vermuten auch dass diese region
auch ähnliche funktionen haben zum
beispiel bei einem hund
[Musik]
an der altarwand universität wollen
wissenschaftler herausfinden wie sich
emotionen in den gehirnen von hunden
abspielen
deshalb schauen sie hunden leicht beim
denken zu etwas das vor wenigen jahren
noch für völlig unmöglich gehalten wurde
heute ist der schärferen theo der
proband betreut wird er von seiner
besitzerin und überwacht von
neurobiologen attila an die tür wird für
lange acht minuten im
magnetresonanztomographen seine
hirnströme messen lassen
dazu muss er absolut still liegen
bleiben damit der scanner ein scharfes
bild von den vorgängen in seinem gehirn
machen kann
das galt bis vor kurzem unter neurologen
als unmöglich wir haben die ungarn das
hingekriegt
es ist unglaublich diese hunde
absolvieren ein training in dem sie
lernen absolut reibungslos für sechs
sieben acht minuten zu verharren während
sie die kopfhörer und den detektor
tragen und mir ihre hirnaktivität messe
der trick der ungarischen
wissenschaftler
es werden immer zwei hunde gleichzeitig
trainiert
ein profi der schon alles kann und ein
neuling der noch keine ahnung hat und
das geschehen erst einmal beobachten
soll
der profi wird von den trainern für
jeden schritt derartig gelobt dass der
neuling es kaum abwarten kann ebenfalls
so schnell wie möglich auf der bank zu
liegen und dafür bewundert zu werden
[Musik]
das ist sogar besser als jedes leckerli
ohne zwang und druck nur mit bestätigung
gelingt es die tiere zudem für hunde und
typischen verhalten zu motivieren
[Musik]
mit dieser methode ist auch bei dem
neuling nach einer halben stunde der
anfang gemacht
[Musik]
im magnetresonanztomographen kann das
experiment jetzt beginnen über die
kopfhörer bekommt theo geräusche
eingespielt die neurobiologen wollen
herausfinden wie ähnlich sich menschen
und hunde gehirne sind
welche bereiche werden bei schärferen
theo durch diese geräusche stimuliert
und fällt die stimulation je nach art
der laute unterschiedlich aus zum
beispiel wenn der hund die stimme seines
besitzers oder die eines anderen hundes
hört die ergebnisse sind sensationell
lange zeit hatten die neurobiologen
angenommen dass es nur bei primaten eine
region im gehirn gibt die ausschließlich
für die verarbeitung von lauten der
eigenen art zuständig ist ein irrtum wie
die ungarischen forschungsergebnisse
zeigen
hunde haben ebenso wie menschen einen
bereich im gehirn der auf das erkennen
von lauten der eigenen art spezialisiert
ist
beim menschen gibt es den gleichen
großen teil des auditiven kortex der
sich stärker für menschliche laute als
für die andere arten interessiert wir
hatten keine ahnung dass es auch bei
hunden einen solchen bereich gibt das
ist ein sehr wichtiges
forschungsergebnis es bedeutet dass man
die gemeinsame evolutionsgeschichte von
menschen und hunden in einem ganz neuen
licht sehen muss
eines ist nun wissenschaftlich erwiesen
die laut verarbeitung in den gehirnen
von hunden und menschen ist weniger
unterschiedlich als man bisher geglaubt
hat
wenn die gehirne einander so ähnlich
sind wie schaut es dann mit dem sinn für
gerechtigkeit und fairness aus um clever
dog lab in wien werden kognitive und
emotionale fähigkeiten von hunden
erforscht bei diesem experiment sollen
zwei hunde bötchen geben
das besondere der eine bekommt eine
belohnung der andere nicht die
wissenschaftler wollen herausfinden wie
wird der der nichts bekommt auf die
ungerechte behandlung reagieren
[Musik]
mädchen geben das kann border collie
dame ging es richtig gut
und das macht sie normalerweise gern
auch wenn es dafür keine besondere
belohnung gibt aber wenn der hund neben
ihr fürs köpfchen geben eine belohnung
bekommt sie dagegen nichts dann versteht
die hündin die welt nicht mehr
ob die trainerin sich vielleicht geirrt
hat
[Musik]
die trainerin gibt ihr nichts obwohl sie
doch genau dasselbe macht wie der hund
neben ihr gehen es ist beleidigt und
stellt die arbeit damals jetzt zwei
hunde gehabt und im gegensatz zu affen
reagieren hunde nicht darauf wenn er
eine schlechteres futter bekommt aber
sie reagieren durchaus wenn er nichts
bekommen die wir gerade gesehen haben
sie verweigern also jannis arbeiten und
machen einfach nicht mehr mit irgendwann
hört jeder aufzuarbeiten wenn sie dafür
nicht belohnt werden
das werden sie auch machen hier an der
emory university beschäftigt sich
verhaltensforscher frans de waal
ebenfalls mit der frage nach fairness
und gerechtigkeit in der tierwelt merken
tiere wenn es ungerecht zugeht und wie
reagieren sie darauf
was geschieht wenn ein kapuzineräffchen
ungerecht behandelt wird zeigt ein
klassischer versuch des instituts
[Musik]
zwei äffchen spielen mit der
wissenschaftlerin das spiel gibt mir den
stein dann kriegst du ein stück gurke
steinburg steinburg
da bekommt das äffchen auf der rechten
seite auf einmal als belohnung eine
traum
das äffchen auf der linken seite mag
nicht glauben dass es weiterhin nur
gurke kriegen soll
[Musik]
und als die ungerechte behandlung sogar
noch fortgesetzt wird rastet das äffchen
aus und verweigert die mitarbeiter
[Musik]
wir stellten fest dass das äffchen dass
weiterhin die gurke bekam sich sehr sehr
aufregt und keineswegs zufrieden mit der
situation und das obwohl gurken
ansonsten eine beliebte belohnung für
affen sind das heißt der wert einer
belohnung ist davon abhängig was der
andere bekommt
wir nennen das abneigung gegen
ungerechtigkeit ähnlich dem menschlichen
sind wir fans
ich will nicht behaupten dass
kapuzineräffchen einen dem menschen
vergleichbaren sind für fairness haben
das sind die schimpansen sicher näher
dran aber die kapuzineräffchen zeigten
eine sehr ursprüngliche reaktion wie bei
kleinkindern in ihr geschwisterkind
etwas besseres bekommt als sie selber
dann fangen sie an zu protestieren
für franz der wahl ist der sinn für
gerechtigkeit evolutionär bedingt und
keineswegs eine ausschließlich
menschliche eigenschaft wenn menschen
über moral reflektieren und über
fairness und gerechtigkeit dann sind das
enorm komplizierte geistige konzept und
da kommen wir daher und präsentieren
affen die auf die gleiche art auf
ungerechtigkeit werden eine erkenntnis
die dazu führt dass der mensch sondern
anspruch auf einzigartigkeit verliert
ist moral einer eigenschaft von tieren
bei kurt kotrschal im wolf science
center in ernstbrunn sind die string
pulling versuche weiter gegangen
alles lief glatt perfekte kooperation
doch beim fünften durchlauf des tests
fällt der junge aragon es einfach nicht
mehr aus er zieht schon mal an dem seil
die strafe folgt auf dem fuß wird die
junge wolf aragon daraus lernen
wenn wir jetzt nach moralfragen dann ist
die antwort des biologen dass moral
sozusagen eine anpassung an komplexes
sozialleben ist ganz einfach definiert
wer unmoralisches verhalten aus dass
sich der gruppe das was man sich nicht
gerne zumuten lassen will oder aus dass
ich das individuums das was man anderen
nicht zumuten sollte weil sonst weil
sonst sind die nicht zufrieden wie etwa
heute oder wie etwa bei diesem string
pulling experiment aragorn einer der
wölfe einmal zu oft am seil gezogen hat
bevor kasper da war und so das ende von
kasper entfernt hat und er es nicht mehr
reichen konnte was hat casper gemacht
hat sofort sanktioniert sofort zu ärgern
rüber hat in kurz angebraten und was war
am nächsten beim nächsten durchgang hat
aragon nicht einmal nicht einmal gewagt
das seilende anzurühren und hat gewartet
also das war eindeutig ein verstoß gegen
die regeln und das bezeichnen was machen
ich glaube an die evolution und sehe sie
als kontinuierlichen prozess ich sehe
mich als tier als säugetier als primat
tatsächlich wenn ich so tag für tag
meiner ratten sehe dann komme ich zu dem
schluss dass ich einfach eine etwas
höhere rate bin ich habe vielleicht
etwas mehr gehirnrinde aber ich bin
nicht so weit weg von ihren ich denke
heutzutage akzeptieren viele
wissenschaftler dass etliche arten die
fähigkeit haben emotionen zu empfinden
wir menschen sind auch tiere deshalb
glaube ich nicht dass es so große
unterschiede gibt zwischen menschlichen
und nichtmenschlichen tieren
verantwortungsvolle affen beleidigte
hunde hilfsbereite ratten
kooperative haben selbstbewusste
elefanten
wir werden unsere meinung über das
gefühlsleben der tiere ändern müssen
manche leute sagen menschen haben mehr
gefühle oder verschiedenartige
rückgeführt
ich bin nicht davon überzeugt ich glaube
eher dass sich das gefühlsleben aller
säugetiere im grunde gleicht freddy und
victor sind unzertrennlich
die sonne senkt sich über den regenwald
freddy hat dem kleinen waisenkind
einlässt für die nacht gebaut
und er hat es adoptiert aus reinen
mitgefühl
[Musik]